et bien bonjour à tous et à toutes chers
Président chers Stéphane chers collègues
mesdames nous poursuivons ce matin nos
travaux sur la parentalité dans les
outre-mer bienvenue à la rapporteur
qui rejoint l'autre rapporteur victoire
jasmin donc ces travaux sur la
parentalité dans les outre-mer en commun
par nos deux délégations la délégation
aux outre-mer président de droite
Stéphane Artano et la délégation aux
droits des femmes que j'ai l'honneur de
préciser outre les présidents des deux
délégations sont également rapporteurs
victoires jasmin sénatrice
des territoires ultramarins la
Guadeloupe et elles achalke c'est un
petit peu plus à l'est donc c'est
beaucoup moins ultra marin en réalité
mais tout à fait investi sur le sujet et
qui connaît bien ses territoires aussi
nous entendons tout d'abord ce matin des
représentants d'Unicef France madame
Jody Soret responsable du service
programme et plaidoyer et Madame
mathildeprés chargée de plaidoyer
programme outre-mer bon bienvenue à vous
mesdames nos attentes s'articulent
autour de deux axes premièrement
connaître les actions menées par
l'UNICEF dans les territoires
d'outre-mer et savoir comment vous
adapter vos missions d'action sociale à
ces territoires davantage tous chez par
la précarité en particulier la précarité
des mères seuls l'annonce colorisation
et le décrochage scolaire en réalité des
jeunes les grosses esprits précoces ou
encore la présence de mineurs non
accompagnés en grande difficulté
deuxièmement nous souhaitons connaître
les recommandations de l'UNICEF afin
d'améliorer la situation des enfants et
famille d'outre-mer à travers nos
travaux nous sommes à la recherche de
solutions et évidemment d'outils pour
que nos politiques familiales et
sociales tiennent davantage compte des
particularités ultramarines pour
améliorer le soutien à la parentalité
dans nos territoires
ultramarins je vous remercie donc pour
votre présence ce matin très matinale je
laisse sans plus tarder la parole à
mesdames je n'y serai et Mathilde
destret et donc vous vous organisez
comme vous le souhaitez au niveau de la
prise de parole mesdames bienvenue et
c'est à vous vous devez brancher le
micro quand vous parlez et l'éteindre
surtout quand vous ne parlez pas voilà
ce que je vais faire moi immédiatement
alors je m'essaye au micro c'est
mouvementez bien bonjour madame la
Présidente bonjour monsieur le Président
Mesdames leur rapporteur bonjour à
toutes et tous Tout d'abord merci
beaucoup de nous recevoir aujourd'hui
pour parler de ce sujet qui est un sujet
en effet très important que nous on
n'apporte plus généralement sur la
question des droits de l'enfant dans les
territoires ultramarins il nous a fallu
un petit peu de temps pour y venir
puisque longtemps c'est vrai que nos
recommandations en matière de plaidoyer
se sont concentrés davantage sur
l'hexagone et puis on s'est rendu compte
notamment à l'occasion bon on s'est
rendu compte progressivement mais
notamment à l'occasion d'un état des
lieux ou plutôt d'une analyse de la
situation des droits de l'enfant en
France que un certain nombre
d'indicateurs concernant les territoires
ultramarins nous alerter
particulièrement et venez finalement
objectiver une situation qu'on avait pu
pressentir d'une autre manière donc
peut-être pour représenter un peu plus
globalement l'action de l'UNICEF en
France donc l'UNICEF en France
représente l'UNICEF donc nous avons un
mandat pour représenter l'agence des
Nations unies pour l'enfance sur le
territoire français et évidemment
l'ensemble du territoire français donc
nous sommes un comité national dans les
principales missions sont le plaidoyer
la communication la sensibilisation et
également la collecte puisque la
collecte notamment pour financer des
programmes dans les pays en
développement à long temps été on va
dire l'arête dorsale en tout cas de
l'action de l'UNICEF en France et puis
les choses ont beaucoup évolué puisque
aujourd'hui le service compte 15
personnes donc le service plaidoyer
compte 15 personnes ce qui nous permet
quand même de couvrir un certain nombre
de sujets
parmi lesquels pour présenter tout de
suite nos priorités la protection au
sens large nous incluons notamment les
questions de pauvreté sous le chapeau de
la protection également les enjeux de
santé mentale des enfants ce qui est un
sujet important les enjeux vraiment de
protection de l'enfance incluant aussi
la question de la prise en charge des
mineurs en situation de migration
et puis nous travaillons aussi sur les
questions d'éducation des enfants
notamment la question de l'accès à
l'éducation et je me permets de préciser
ces thématiques puisque c'est notamment
celle que nous avons commencé à
approfondir dans notre travail sur les
différentes territoires ultramarins donc
le rôle de l'UNICEF est finalement de
formule des recommandations en direction
des pouvoirs publics pour améliorer
l'effectivité des droits de l'enfant sur
le territoire pour cela nous contribuons
très fortement
aux travaux qui sont menés par le Comité
des droits de l'enfant de Genève dans le
cadre de l'examen qu'il mène tous les
cinq à six ans de la mise en oeuvre de
la Convention des droits de l'enfant en
France donc on attend des
recommandations notamment pour le mois
de juin de la part du Comité des droits
de l'enfant et nous avons dans ce
cadre-là beaucoup porté le sujet des
territoires ultramarins donc il est très
fort probable que des des
recommandations de la part du Comité des
droits de l'enfant à l'endroit de la
France seront seront diffusés à partir
de à partir de juin
France a souhaité renforcé son action
sur l'effectivité des droits des enfants
dans les territoires ultramarins comme
je le disais on avait déjà commencé un
travail notamment en Guyane sur l'accès
à l'éducation puisque en 2020 nous
avions publié une étude sur l'éducation
en Guyane qui faisait notamment 37
recommandations autour de trois thèmes
favoriser l'accès à l'éducation des
enfants éloignés de l'école contribuer
au renforcement des conditions de
réussite éducatives des enfants et
renforcer la connaissance et la capacité
des acteurs à respecter et promouvoir
les droits de l'enfant donc en Guyane
depuis la publication de ce rapport donc
nous avons un salarié qui se trouve en
Guyane et qui travaille pour la
réalisation de ces différentes
recommandations et donc nous pourrons y
revenir un peu plus en détail par la
suite notamment quand nous parlerons
d'éducation
et puis comme je le mentionnais un peu
plus tôt entre 2020 et 2021 nous avons
mené plus globalement un travail sur
l'effectivité des droits de l'enfant sur
le territoire français et là à ce moment
là c'est vrai qu'on s'est rendu compte
de plusieurs choses déjà un certain
nombre de données qui manquait
concernant l'effectivité des droits des
enfants dans les territoires ultramarins
avec vraiment des situations et vraiment
on insiste sur des territoires
ultramarins parce que y compris sur le
sujet des données c'est très inégales ce
qu'on peut trouver par exemple on manque
vraiment beaucoup de données concernant
la Polynésie la Nouvelle-Calédonie alors
qu'on va pouvoir en trouver davantage
quand on parle de la Guadeloupe par
exemple même si évidemment on est très
exigeant s'agissant des données parce
qu'il nous semble elle nous semble être
la base de bonne politique publique et
donc une de nos recommandations c'est
certain sera de renforcer le travail
autour des données notamment concernant
les enfants
cet état des lieux dont Mathilde va vous
dire
un peu plus il était en cours donc on se
présente aussi devant vous avec une
certaine humilité qui est ce travail
nous aussi et nous sommes en train de le
faire pour essayer de mieux comprendre
la situation et pouvoir proposer les
solutions les plus adaptées il sera
publié le 20 novembre prochain à
l'occasion de la Journée des droits de
l'enfant avec vraiment un objectif pour
l'Unicef France qui est de vraiment
mettre la focale sur finalement
l'égalité entre les territoires et
notamment la nécessité de peut-être
avoir une on va dire une action un peu
renforcée pour s'assurer de
l'effectivité des droits des enfants en
outre-mer
nous nous nourrissons donc pour le
moment des données et des recherches
disponibles
mais nous sommes également nous
souhaitons également associer les
acteurs concernés sur les territoires
donc nous menons un certain nombre de
d'auditions avec des acteurs pour
essayer de comprendre un peu plus
finement les réalités et surtout on va
dire ne pas faire d'amalgame y compris
entre des territoires qu'on a parfois
désignés comme l'outre-mer en général et
puis sur lequel voilà je pense qu'il y a
une réflexion pas seulement de notre
côté d'ailleurs
donc pour le moment on peut pas dire
qu'on prétend mais même plus globalement
compétents ni à l'exhaustivité ni à la
perfection mais l'idée c'est vraiment
pour nous on va dire de d'avoir une mise
de départ aussi sur cette question de
l'effectivité des droits des enfants et
ensuite de pouvoir évidemment
co-construire des solutions donc les
réflexions que nous allons partager avec
vous aujourd'hui reflète les premiers
travaux que nous avons pu engager et
puis certaines des contributions aux
politiques publiques que nous avons pu
proposer puisque on va dire qu'en
parallèle nous avons quand même souhaité
commencer à formuler des propositions
notamment dans le cadre des Assises de
la santé de l'enfant puisque nous
semblait avoir des besoins assez
spécifiques malgré tout sur les enjeux
de santé également dans le cadre de la
préparation du Pacte des solidarités
puisque comme vous le disiez la
précarité est particulièrement
prévalente donc je passe la parole à
merci beaucoup vous m'entendez bien
super mais je me permets de reprendre la
parole après l'intervention de Jodie
Soray
alors comme Jodie Sorel a dit on est en
train d'établir un état des lieux sur la
situation des droits de l'enfant dans
les territoires ultramarins je vais
essayer de dérouler de manière
synthétique les premiers concerts
recommandations qu'on a fait mais on
espère laisser quand même de la place
aux questions et aux échanges qui nous
semblent quand même tout aussi
importants donc on a commencé des
travaux notamment sur la thématique
pauvreté on s'est rendu compte que la
connaissance et l'analyse de la
situation des enfants sont essentiels
pour objectiver leurs besoins et pour
développer des politiques publiques
adaptées on se confronte mais d'ailleurs
pas que nous à un double obstacle qui
est comme l'a dit jeudi le manque de
données sur la pauvreté
multidimensionnelle des enfants en
général mais plus particulièrement dans
les territoires d'outre-mer et puis le
manque de données pour les territoires
ultramarins qui est quand même assez
assez prévenant
à titre d'exemple jusqu'à récemment donc
en 2020 le seuil de pauvreté utilisé
pour mesurer le taux de pauvreté en
outre-mer n'était pas le seuil de
pauvreté nationale ce qui est compliqué
l'analyse
enfin de la pauvreté multidimensionnelle
c'est pour ça que à ce titre on
recommande à l'Unicef de réaliser tout
d'abord un état des lieux sur la
pauvreté multidimensionnelle des enfants
qui vivent dans les collectivités
territoriales d'outre-mer on considère
aussi que le Pacte des solidarités qui
est en cours et pour lequel l'UNICEF
mène un travail conséquent est un levier
parce qu'il a notamment vocation à être
décliné localement dans le cadre d'une
contractualisation état et collectivité
et qu'il prévoit une adaptation des
politiques de lutte contre la pauvreté à
certains territoires dont les
territoires ultramarins
là aussi on a formulé des
recommandations qu'on pourra vous
transmettre
à posteriori mais à ce tritre en
recommande vraiment de s'assurer de la
mise en oeuvre effective des mesures du
Pacte des solidarités dans les
territoires ultramarins en les adaptant
au contexte tout en visant les mêmes
résultats puisque des adaptations sont
en effet nécessaire mais elles sont
acceptables uniquement si l'ambition des
mesures n'est pas revu à la baisse pour
ces territoires on sait aussi rendu
compte que la barrière de la langue est
un obstacle dans certains territoires
dit d'outre-mer notamment dans l'accès
aux services publics et aux droits c'est
pour ça qu'on recommande aussi dans le
cadre du Pacte des solidarités notamment
de développer une stratégie
d'interprétariat pour favoriser l'accès
aux services publics et aux droits des
familles
je me permets de faire un une petite
précision par rapport au logement
puisque ça me semble essentiel d'évoquer
les logements dans les territoires
d'outre-mer puisque selon le rapport
d'information sénatorielle du 1er
juillet 2021 l'habitat indigne près de
110 000 logements soit 13 % du parc des
900000 logements des drones des drones
pardon donc les difficultés d'accès au
logement en outre-mer elles sont
fortement accentuées aussi par
l'existence d'un système dérogatoire aux
droits communs ou certains droits sont
minorés voire inappliqués par exemple le
droit au logement opposable n'est pas
forcément en vigueur et certains droits
sociaux ne sont pas alignés avec le
droit commun en tout cas en hexagone
c'est le cas notamment du revenu de
solidarité active ou des allocations
logement donc il y a une distinction
nette quand même qui est faite entre les
collectivités territoriales d'outre-mer
et l'hexagone et ça se retrouve
également dans les textes du coup
applicables on peut parler de la
circulaire du 26 août 2021 relative à
l'anticipation des opérations
d'évacuation des campements illicites et
l'instruction de du 25 janvier 2018
relative à la résorption des campements
illicites et des bidonvilles qui est
censé viser à la réduction durable du
nombre de bidonvilles dans les cinq ans
à venir et qui ne s'appliquent pas dans
les territoires d'outre-mer
donc face à l'ampleur de la dégradation
de l'habitat et l'augmentation des
logements insolubles insulument le
législateur il a introduit du coup des
dispositions spécifiques censées
faciliter la résorption de l'habitat
c'est le cas de la loi Elan qui a été
introduite en 2018 et qui concerne une
profonde réforme sur le logement social
et l'habitat informel en Guyane et à
Mayotte
l'application de la loi Elan elle a des
conséquences concrètes en Guyane à
Mayotte notamment on peut parler aussi
de l'actualité notamment lors de
l'opération qui est en cours à Mayotte
l'application de la loi Elan a des
conséquences sur notamment la
scolarisation des enfants et
l'hébergement des enfants mais on pourra
y revenir après si ce sujet vous
intéresse dans ce cadre là sur vraiment
la thématique pauvreté nous on
recommande de renforcer le repérage et
l'orientation des familles sans domicile
vers le droit commun en développant et
en pérennisant les dispositifs visant à
aller vers ces familles qui pour nous
est un dispositif tout à fait pertinent
on insiste aussi sur le fait de garantir
un accueil inconditionnel des enfants et
des familles en hébergement
respectueux de leurs droits en
développement des solutions
d'hébergement adaptées aux familles ce
qui n'est pas forcément toujours le cas
et puis ça c'est une recommandation
générale mais on recommande aussi de
favoriser l'accès au logement donc de
produire massivement une offre de
logement très sociaux adapté aux
familles il y a déjà un travail qui est
en cours
mais on recommande de le renforcer et
puis la dernière recommandation
peut-être sur ce point on recommande
vraiment d'intégrer les territoires
d'outre-mer dans le programme national
de résorption des bidonvilles et la
circulaire de 2018 que nous avions
évoqué
peut-être si on continue sur la
thématique protection puisqu'à l'UNICEF
on travaille aussi par thématique si je
peux me permettre de parler du sujet
migration il y a certaines dérogations
législatives qui sont propres à certains
territoires ultramarins qui font état
encore une fois d'un non accès
systémique au droit de l'enfant c'est
notamment le cas à Mayotte mais aussi
sur d'autres territoires mais à Mayotte
c'est particulièrement exacerbé ou le
droit des personnes étrangères il est
dérogatoire dans de nombreux domaines
santé liberté de circulation pour les
mineurs contrôle d'identité mais
également accès à la nationalité ou
accès à un titre de séjour et donc le
régime dérogatoire il plonge souvent des
milliers de familles et d'enfants dans
une situation particulièrement
vulnérable et à des conséquences
directes sur la parentalité au sein même
des familles je pourrais développer
après si vous avez des questions sur la
liberté de circulation mais également
les conséquences de la réforme de
l'accès à la nationalité ou encore
l'enfermement des enfants qui est
particulièrement prégnant à Mayotte ou
plus de 2900 enfants ont été enfermés en
l'année dernière donc c'est aussi un
sujet qu'on porte à l'Unicef de la fin
de l'enfermement des mineurs sur
l'ensemble du territoire et dans tous
les locaux de rétention pas forcément un
centre de rétention c'est pour ça que
nous on préfère on recommande
d'appliquer le droit commun qui est
prévu par le CZ pour toutes les mesures
dérogatoires qui entraînent des
conséquences négatives sur la
réalisation des droits de l'enfant donc
c'est vraiment le prisme des droits de
l'enfant qui doit selon nous primer et
puis mettre fin l'enfermement des
enfants dans tous les dans tous les
lieux de rétention et dans tous les
territoires mais ça paraît que je l'ai
déjà mentionné sur l'aspect protection
aussi vous nous aviez posé une question
sur le cas des grossesses précoces qui
effectivement un enjeu alors sur
certains territoires mais
particulièrement en Guyane et à Mayotte
je vais peut-être pas m'étendre sur le
sujet parce que je sais que le réseau
périnatal de Guyane a aussi été
auditionné et on est souvent en échange
avec eux nous les freins qu'on constate
c'est les mêmes finalement que le réseau
périnatal de Guyane c'est des carences
bon qui sont généralisées en termes
d'infrastructures et particulièrement
santé mentale je fais une petite
parenthèse mais le taux de suivi des
quand même 8 fois plus élevé en Guyane
selon santé publique France donc ça a
forcément des conséquences sur la
réalisation des droits de l'enfant et ça
touche particulièrement les enfants
Amérindiens
le réseau périnatal nous a aussi fait
part d'une prévention qui est parfois
inadaptée qui est plutôt calqué sur le
modèle hexagonal et qui est pas
forcément adapté aux réalités de la
Guyane et puis aussi le cas des
grossesses précoces entraîne une non
scolarisation voire une déscolarisation
dans le cadre de la grossesse qui s'agit
quand même d'identifier pour pour
pallier ce manque d'accès à l'éducation
donc nous à ce titre on recommande
vivement de renforcer l'accompagnement
des adolescentes enceintes à travers
l'augmentation des moyens loués au
dispositif donc ça peut être notamment
via le réseau périnatal de Guyane avec
la création de postes référents mais pas
que sur le littoral mais également dans
les communes les plus isolées de Guyane
on trouvait ça intéressant aussi de
proposer la création de nouveaux postes
d'accompagnement à la parentalité pour
accompagner les maires et les couples
jusqu'au 3 ans de l'enfant et pas
forcément jusque jusqu'à la naissance et
jusqu'à l'entrée en fait dans la
scolarité des enfants
on trouve ça intéressant aussi ce qui
est fait en Guyane et on souhaiterait
que ça puisse se poursuivre de
développer les permanences sages-femmes
en milieu scolaire ça se fait déjà dans
certains établissements et on trouve que
c'est une solution qui est plutôt
pertinente et intéressante et qui serait
peut-être à développer on aimerait aussi
doter enfin que le territoire soit doté
de foyer parentaux ce qui n'est pas le
cas actuellement pour pallier un petit
peu l'isolement des adolescentes et de
prévoir un accompagnement global donc
qui soit matériel psychologique
également pédagogique et puis sur
l'ensemble du territoire enfin ça vaut
pour tous les territoires mais on
souhaite vraiment recommander de
privilégier et de renforcer les actions
de sensibilisation avec l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés notamment dans les
établissements scolaires puisque c'est
là aussi que la sensibilisation passe et
pour se faire on recommande notamment de
développer des plans de formation qui
soit adaptées c'est aussi des remontées
du terrain qu'on a qui soit adapté aux
réalités des territoires aux
professionnels de santé mais également
professionnel de l'éducation nationale
qui fait état des réalités sociales
culturelles historiques dans ces
territoires ultramarins
on souhaitait dire aussi quelques mots
concernant l'éducation puisqu'on vous a
indiqué que c'était un sujet sur lequel
on travaille depuis un certain temps
déjà notamment s'agissant de l'Hexagone
mais on avait publié un rapport sur la
situation de l'éducation en Guyane dans
lequel on
estimait environ à 10000 le nombre
d'enfants n'ayant pas accès à
l'éducation on avait d'ailleurs repris
des chiffres de la Cour des comptes même
si ces estimations sont toujours assez
difficiles à faire des travaux plus
récents estimes à 9500 le nombre
d'enfants à Mayotte qui n'aurait pas
accès à l'éducation donc c'est un sujet
sur lequel nous travaillons beaucoup et
je pense que dans les mois qui viennent
on renforcera probablement aussi notre
action à Mayotte sur ce sur ce sujet là
dans les freins que nous avons
identifié alors là je parle plus
spécifiquement de la Guyane puisque
c'est là que nous avons travaillé
jusqu'ici donc notamment une absence de
repérage et d'identification des enfants
non scolarisés
le code de l'éducation impose aux
municipalités de dresser la liste de
tous les enfants soumis à l'obligation
scolaire mais cette disposition n'est
pas toujours voire parfois très peu
appliqué sur les territoires ce qui
laisse dans l'invisibilité un certain
nombre d'enfants non scolarisés et
l'absence de recensement empêche le
repérage des enfants et en conséquence
leur accompagnement on voit bien que
notamment dans certains quartiers
informels et des très difficiles de
savoir si l'ensemble des enfants sont
scolarisés ou pas ce qui met évidemment
en difficulté la collecte de données de
qualité comme on le disait tout à
l'heure des difficultés d'inscription à
l'école aussi du fait parfois de
pratiques qui sont illégales de la part
de certaines municipalités donc on a
noté que c'était assez pris dans
notamment en Guyane à Mayotte aussi
parfois notamment concernant des enfants
étrangers qui se trouvent de fait privé
de scolarisation
la défenseur donc je vais pas peut-être
revenir dans le dans le détail mais
c'est notamment des sujets sur lesquels
la Défenseur des droits a rendu un
certain nombre de décisions
à Mayotte nous avons aussi
en tout cas relever des dispositifs sans
ces palier le manque de place dans les
établissements scolaires donc le
rectorat de Mayotte a des a décidé la
mise en oeuvre d'un dispositif
dérogatoire de classe itinérante donc
plusieurs associations notamment la LDH
le style Fasti mais également la scène
cdH et le Défenseur des droits à relever
que les enfants nationalités français
sera ainsi scolarisés de préférence dans
des écoles de la commune et que les
enfants étrangers sont généralement
accueillis une matinée par semaine dans
le cas de dispositif de classes
itinérante ce qui nous semble
possiblement quand même être une
différence de traitement qui en tout cas
retient notre attention
donc la justice saisit ce dispositif par
le biais des associations à considérer
que cette solution ne saurait être
regardée comme un palliatif et une
scolarisation effective donc ça renforce
quand même l'idée que il y a un vrai
travail qui doit être mené pour que
l'ensemble des enfants puissent avoir
accès à ce droit à l'éducation enfin ce
qui peut également faire barrage à la
scolarisation des enfants c'est des
conditions de logement de transport
parfois de restauration qui rendent
difficile l'accès et le maintien à
l'école notamment l'enjeu des transports
scolaires ou le manque de place en
internat qui conduit à mettre en place
par exemple le dispositif de famille
hébergente en Guyane qui était un
dispositif Haddock qui répond certaines
qui répond certes à un besoin mais qui
nous semble parfois ne pas forcément
aller dans le dans le sens de la
meilleure protection des enfants puisque
c'est un dispositif malgré tout qui nous
semble parfois un petit peu opaque donc
parmi nos recommandations pour suivre et
pérenniser le travail engagé autour de
l'identification des enfants éloignés de
l'école en incluant dans une démarche
nationale puisque l'enjeu de la non
accès à l'éducation n'est pas non plus
seulement un problème de territoire
ultramarins mais que il existe aussi des
enfants dans hexagone qui ne sont pas
scolarisés et donc pour nous c'est
important finalement que cette
observatoire de la scolarisation et de
la réussite éducative qui a été relancée
on s'en félicite en Guyane puis
s'inscrire dans un sous un chapeau un
peu plus un peu plus global aussi pour
armée harmoniser les méthodologies
donc nous on pousse cette observatoire
national de l'annonce scolarisation
aussi pour avoir des réflexions au
niveau au niveau national sur ce sujet
là on s'intéresse aussi beaucoup au
développement de la médiation scolaire
puisque c'est un alors je ne sais pas si
vous connaissez bien ce dispositif mais
on pourrait y revenir si vous le
souhaitez de médiation scolaire qui a
été mis en place notamment par la dial
et qui aujourd'hui se concentrer
essentiellement sur l'hexagone et qui
nous semblerait intéressant de pouvoir
élargir notamment au territoire
ultramarins en l'adaptant évidemment
avec d'autant qu'on sait que certaines
initiatives ressemblant à la médiation
scolaire existe déjà mais sans rentrer
sous ce sous on va dire
alors la gestion en tout cas par la dial
et puis ancrer les dispositifs Haddock
applicables dans certains territoires
d'outre-mer dans le droit commun il peut
y avoir en effet un droit d'initiative
locale qui peut être très intéressant
mais dans ce cas là il faut s'assurer
que c'est vraiment on va dire pour le
mieux et vraiment pour une meilleure
réalisation des droits de l'enfant pour
une meilleure adaptation mais surtout on
essaie d'éviter des dispositifs qui
finalement consisteraient à avoir une
moins bonne implication des droits de
l'enfant je repasse la parole à Mathilde
très pour les sujets santé
merci beaucoup on va peut-être terminer
notre propos sur la question de santé et
puis après on pourra échanger dans le
cadre des questions réponses si vous en
avez sur la santé simplement des
constats mais que qui enfin qui sont
très certainement partagés le rapport de
Liga sur la santé des enfants affirment
en 2021 que les indicateurs de santé
ainsi que les déterminants de santé des
enfants sont plus défavorables dans les
territoires d'outre-mer qu'en métropole
on en a parlé mais la pauvreté monétaire
est multidimensionnelle qui frappent
certains des territoires ultramarins
elle est de faite passe en conséquence
sur le parcours de santé des enfants qui
représentent quand même une part
importante de la population surtout dans
certains territoires mais à titre
d'exemple la mortalité infantile elle
est deux à trois fois plus élevée dans
les drones qu'en hexagone et de fait la
santé des enfants elle est
particulièrement dégradée sur certains
sur certains territoires qui souffrent
de carences dans l'offre de soins et les
infrastructures de santé en général mais
également l'offre de soins hospitalières
en pédopsychiatrie qui fait pas
exception à ses carences et la prise en
compte de l'importance de la prise en
charge des enfants en santé mentale et
aussi un enjeu fondamental c'est une de
nos priorités aussi à l'Unicef France
surtout dans ces territoires où l'accès
aux soins dit essentiels qui comprend
pas forcément les soins en santé mentale
de prime abord mais c'est vraiment aussi
un parcours sommet d'obstacles nous on
recommande tout de même vivement pour ce
qui est de la santé de développer et de
renforcer les dispositifs mobiles
d'accès aux soins qui existent déjà et
qui font leurs preuves sur certains
territoires et la prévention aussi en
médiation de santé en ascension
l'ensemble des acteurs concernés afin
d'entamer une réelle démarche d'aller
vers qui fonctionne qui a fait ses
preuves et nous on recommande vraiment
de de renforcer cette démarche d'aller
vers les enfants éloignés des
infrastructures adaptées à leur prise en
charge
on souhaite aussi apporter à votre
connaissance les Francs en matière de
soins et de protection maladie dans
certains territoires dit ultramarins
nous on recommande vivement de mettre en
place l'aide médicale d'État et la
complémentaire santé solidaire à Mayotte
sans aucune distinction on souhaite
aussi recommander la filiation enfin de
permettre l'affiliation à la sécurité
sociale de tous les enfants peu importe
la situation administrative de l'oeuvre
par an ou la situation d'isolement ce
qui n'est pas forcément encore le cas
sur sur l'ensemble du territoire
français
on aimerait aussi peut-être évoquer
rapidement à la situation de la
procédure d'évacuation sanitaire je sais
pas si c'est une procédure que vous
connaissez mais qui qui existe qui est
plutôt opaque aussi en fonction des
territoires mais qui existent surtout de
Mayotte vers la Réunion mais également
de la Guyane vers l'Hexagone nous on
aimerait qu'il y ait un travail de fond
qui soit mené qui est déjà mené par
certaines associations sur place
notamment la Cimade à la Réunion mais on
aimerait vraiment un vrai pour la
modification de cette procédure afin de
permettre que les parents
puissent accompagner jusqu'au retour
leurs enfants lorsqu'il bénéficient
d'une évacuation sanitaire d'un
territoire ultramarin à un autre ou d'un
territoire ultramarin à l'Hexagone en
respect du principe de non séparation
des familles et sans distinction en
fonction de la situation administrative
des parents puisque parfois des enfants
se retrouvent à être évacués par exemple
à la Réunion et les difficultés liées à
la délivrance de soit de passeport
provisoire soit de laisser passer fait
que les parents ne peuvent pas
accompagner leurs enfants et des fois
les enfants restent sur un territoire
qui ne connaissent pas pendant des mois
voire certains plusieurs années avec une
rupture dans dans le droit de au respect
de la vie privée familiale qui est quand
même assez conséquent il y a des
réflexions qui sont en cours
actuellement sur cette procédure et puis
enfin qui n'est pas des moindres aussi
on souhaiterait recommander
l'amélioration de l'offre de soi en
santé mentale des enfants et permettre
un suivi efficient donc ça ça passe par
le renforcement des structures adaptées
mais également de valoriser notamment
les actions de prévention du suicide on
par lait des jeunes Amérindiens et en
Guyane mais également d'automatiser le
suivi en santé mentale des enfants
concernés par la destruction de leurs
habitats à Mayotte notamment dans le
cadre de la loi Elan on aimerait que ce
dispositif soit renforcé que les enfants
puissent être accompagnés en dans le
cadre de la prise en charge de leur
santé et santé mentale plus précisément
donc on attachait deux brosser un
certain nombre de recommandations même
si le sujet est très vaste je pense que
voilà vous avez noté que l'ensemble
enfin l'entreprise mais clairement les
droits de l'enfant et l'interprétation
qu'on fait en tout cas de la Convention
des droits de l'enfant aussi basé sur
les recommandations du Comité des droits
de l'enfant donc normalement on a prévu
un petit temps pour pouvoir échanger
donc je vous aide la parole merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup mesdames pour
cette présentation assez très exhaustive
et qui démontre l'engagement aussi de
l'UNICEF sur nos beaux territoires
ultramarins vous avez pointé différents
sujets différentes problématiques je
vais juste vous poser deux petites
questions par laisser la parole ensuite
au rapporteur et au sénateurs sénatrices
qui sont avec nous vous avez parlé de
changement du calcul de seuil de
pauvreté à partir de 2020 je crois
pouvez-vous nous dire pourquoi il y a eu
ce changement à ce moment là et
quels en étaient les conséquences si
vous pouvez noter on prendra toutes les
questions en même temps s'il vous plaît
parce que comme nous sommes contraints
par le temps nous avons une autre
d'audition derrière et vous avez aussi
pointé des différences entre la
métropole et les territoires ultramarins
je vous demande peut-être pas de
répondre de manière exhaustive tout de
suite là ce matin si vous pouviez nous
envoyer précisément les différences que
ce soit sur le RSA sur l'aide au
logement sur les allocations
diverses et variées on va dire sur vous
quand vous avez mentionné un droposable
au logement qui n'était pas une réalité
dans certains territoires est-ce que
vous pourriez nous donner précisément à
la fois cet état des lieux et les
conséquences que ça peut avoir et puis
comme j'ai déjà parlé en introduction et
que je vous ai posé un certain nombre de
questions auxquelles vous avez répondu
je vais maintenant laisser peut-être la
parole au rapporteur et président Stefan
Artano pour quelques questions et
peut-être les rapporteurs et sénateurs
et sénatrices qui sont avec nous ce
matin auront des questions à vous poser
je vous remercie madame
merci cher Annick présidente oui
mesdames merci pour vos précisions moi
je vais aller sur un sujet pratique ou
pratique puisque je sais que l'UNICEF
est ton partenariat avec beaucoup de
collectivités j'ai notamment en tête
celle d'Issy-les-Moulineaux que je
connais très bien puisque on a un lien
partenariat à un moment donné je sais
que l'UNICEF et ton lien avec et que ici
mouineau fait partie des villes amis des
enfants donc c'est une des chartes et
j'aimerais savoir si il existe beaucoup
de collectivités en outre-mer qui sont
signataires de cette charte qui permet
notamment collectivité de pouvoir au
travers des conseils municipaux des
jeunes ou des conseils de jeunesse de
commencer à sensibiliser les jeunes
également sur ces sujets donc je crois
beaucoup au Moyen Âge territorial de
votre action puisque vous avez indiqué
que vous aviez notamment un salarié en
Guyane c'est un territoire que vous
investissez fortement est-ce que vous
envisagez de manière générale des liens
avec des collectivités supports parce
que j'imagine que seul l'UNICEF ne
pourra pas forcément porter au-delà de
votre travail de plaidoyer notamment et
de recommandations est-ce que sur le
vous êtes déjà en lien ou est-ce que
vous envisagez de développer et nous on
est intéressé également dans le travail
que nous faisons de voir de quelle
manière les politiques nationales
pourraient permettre justement des
projections d'acteurs tels que l'UNICEF
par exemple dans les territoires
ultramarins et quels seraient les
mesures qui permettraient de favoriser
le développement de votre implantation
au travers de partenariat ou bien des
implantations directes au titre d'Unicef
par exemple je vous remercie merci
monsieur le Président alors elles
achèlent peut-être et ensuite victoire
jasmin nous rapporteur oui merci madame
la Présidente cher Annick monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup pour vos
interventions et pour effectivement
l'exhaustivité de votre présentation on
voit à quel point l'UNICEF mais nous le
savons est fortement en fait engagé sur
les droits de l'enfant mais aussi sur
une notion qui me paraît presque encore
plus importante qui l'effectivité parce
que on peut avoir des droits mais sans
effectivité finalement
ça n'a peut-être peut-être moins
d'importance si on ne peut pas les
exercer
j'avais peut-être une question aussi
pratiquée pratique puisque si j'ai bien
un suivi en fait le service plaidoyer
c'est aussi en fait le lien avec
l'ensemble en fait des acteurs sur place
c'est de voir un peu quel est votre
regard sur les différents acteurs en
fonction en fait des territoires
ultramarins s'il y a selon vous en fait
des des coordinations des coordinations
à améliorer peut-être des manques qui
peuvent exister ou finalement sur des
territoires ou un acteur prend peut-être
voilà une place importante en la matière
dire également je dans les
recommandations que vous avez pu faire
je suis particulièrement sensible à la
création d'un observatoire national de
l'annonce scolarisation parce que quand
on voit les chiffres qui me paraissent à
la fois inquiétant et je pense que c'est
minimisé mais même effrayant lorsque
l'on les chiffres que vous nous avez
rappelé à la fois en Guyane mais
également en fait à Mayotte on voit que
les recommandations qui peuvent être
faites sont faites pour l'avenir mais la
question quand même qui qui a lieu de se
poser c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait de ces
enfants qui à l'heure actuelle ne sont
pas scolarisés comme vous l'avez rappelé
c'est à peu près 10000 9000 enfants qui
ne sont pas scolarisés à l'heure
actuelle avec toutes les conséquences
que cela peut supposer qu'on imagine
pour l'avenir donc là aussi avec votre
regard même si j'imagine que la question
est assez compliquée je vous remercie
madame la rapporteur victoire jasmin
merci madame la Présidente je vous
remercie pour
cette interventions qui sont assez
complémentaires et quasiment exaucé
toutefois j'ai deux petites questions
concernant le constat que vous avez fait
sur les carences et les inégalités en
fait d'application de certaines
dispositifs ne doit commun dans
l'Hexagone par rapport à nos différents
territoires
est-ce que vous pouvez protéger quelques
précisions et l'autre c'est sur l'accès
aux soins à la qualité des soins bon
c'est vrai qu'il y a de grandes
difficultés un peu partout en France
pour avoir des médecins donc on sait
très bien qu'il y a également des airs
médicaux à certains moments dans
certains territoires mais pour ce qui
concerne la prise en charge des enfants
et au niveau de la santé mentale c'est
un vrai sujet sur l'ensemble de nos
territoires parce qu'il manque une
effectivement des pédopsychiatres et ce
n'est pas évident pour la prise en
charge et vous avez évoqué également les
évacuations sanitaires c'est vrai que
sur les différents territoires
il y a la nécessité de voir comment on
peut sur cette territoire pour éviter
parce que la plupart du temps fait les
évacuations vers l'Hexagone donc pour
voir maîtriser en tout cas les
dispositifs sur les territoires
eux-mêmes trouver de notre alternative
alors est-ce que vous avez des
préconisations à nous faire pour éviter
en tout cas cette isolement des enfants
c'est un vrai sujet parce que très
souvent de Polynésie à l'Hexagone c'est
vrai qu'il y a pas il y a on parle de la
santé mentale mais aussi pour les
cancers des enfants donc les soins se
font quasiment exclusivement ici dans
l'Hexagone donc je ne serai pas à plus
longue dans la mesure où vous avez dit
pression tout ce qu'il fallait merci
beaucoup en tout cas merci Madame la
rapporteur le sénateur tany Mohamed elle
soit dit merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente du Président mes chers
collègues j'aurai deux questions mais
avant quelques observations et quelques
mises au point le système de rotation
qui fait que par manque de classe
nous sommes obligés à Mayotte d'utiliser
la même salle de classe le matin pour
une classe et le soir enfin l'après-midi
pour une autre classe
il est valable pour tout le monde il
n'est pas réservé aux étrangers
d'ailleurs 75% des chèques scolaire à
Mayotte c'est 75% d'échec pour tout le
monde il n'y a pas de distinction entre
les élèves étrangers et les élèves les
élèves mahorés la deuxième chose par
rapport à la destruction des bidonvilles
nous avons ici mené des travaux ici à la
délégation sénatoriale aux outre-mer
pour une procédure rapide de destruction
de bidonville en Guyane et à Mayotte
cette procédure est conforme moi je je
suis très admiratif de votre engagement
mais parfois lorsqu'on vous entend
parler on a l'impression que on n'est
pas en France à Mayotte c'est la loi
française qui est appliquait et le
dispositif de la loi est l'un à
franchi le seuil de constitutionnalité
d'ailleurs récemment une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité avait
été soumise au Conseil d'État et le
Conseil d'État a refusé de déférer la
QPC parce qu'il a estimé que contenu de
ce qui se passait à Mayotte et en Guyane
le dispositif de la loi Elan obéissait
obéissiat à la Constitution et puis
dernière observation des dispositions
qui me tiennent à cœur celle adaptant le
droit de la nationalité à Mayotte il est
hors de question
d'y revenir là le Conseil
constitutionnel après le Conseil d'État
se sont prononcés et la condition
supplémentaire d'un séjour de trois mois
de l'un des parents pour que l'enfant
qui naissent sur le seul maori puisse
acquérir la nationalité française mais
moi Mayotte il y a des gens qui qui me
prennent enfin qui disent que c'est de
la gnognotte et je vous je vous
je vous rappelle si vous n'avez pas
suivi récemment une proposition de loi
du groupe LR propose de supprimer
carrément le droit du sol à Mayotte donc
quand vous demandez un assouplissement
moi je veux bien je veux bien l'entendre
mais au jour où l'on parle les droits
sont préservés tant bien que mal contenu
de la de la situation de la situation à
Mayotte et c'est pour ça que j'ai
deux questions la première que
pensez-vous de la nécessité d'appliquer
la circulaire publiera à Mayotte
aujourd'hui alors que beaucoup de ces
enfants sont des enfants abandonnés
officiellement des MNA et bien la
circulaire aire tolbira qui permet
excusez moi l'expression de dispatcher
certains de ces enfants dans d'autres
départements pour qu'ils puissent s'en
occuper parce que le problème c'est que
les collectivités de Mayotte
ne peuvent plus s'en occuper soit
asphyxiés manque de moyens donc que
pensez-vous de l'application de la
circulaire de Bira et que certains de
ces enfants puissent être dispatchés
dans les départements de l'Hexagone
notamment alors Jean-Luc Mélenchon l'a
proposé donc je me permets de poser ici
la question autant vous dire que tous
les élus mahorés seraient d'accord pour
pour qu'on le fasse parce que Mayotte ne
tient pas Mayotte ne tient pas 77% de la
population vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
et lorsque chaque année là là ça va
commencer
avant la la rentrée scolaire vous voyez
débarquer des dizaines de ce qu'on
appelle des quoi ça scolaires c'est à
dire des quoi c'est quoi ça remplit
d'enfants
parce que en face il y a l'éducation
française en face il y a la nationalité
française en plus de quoi ça sanitaire
donc deuxième question
l'UNICEF
agit partout dans le monde
est-ce que vous avez des actions menées
aux Comores notamment pour aider à la
fixation des populations comoriennes
chez elle dans les trois îles des
Comores parce que au final ça serait la
seule solution la seule solution viable
parce que encore une fois Mayotte a elle
toute seule ne pas accueillir toute
cette misère de l'océan Indien
merci beaucoup sénateur qui forcément
connaît bien son territoire et d'où
l'importance d'être là aussi ce matin
chers collègues donc je vais vous
laisser vous organiser comme vous le
souhaitez pour répondre évidemment nous
sommes un petit peu dans un temps
contraint et il y a des j'imagine qu'il
y a des questions qui sont suffisamment
complexes et longues et n'hésitez pas à
nous envoyer bien entendu tous ces
éléments par mail il viendront compléter
l'audition de ce matin je vous remercie
mesdames on vous écoute
donc compte tenu du fait qu'il nous
reste trois minutes si on respecte
l'heure un peut-être un petit peu plus
ok très bien alors
s'agissant du changement de du calcul de
seuil de pauvreté à partir de 2020 très
honnêtement je pense qu'on pourra pas
vous fournir l'explication là tout de
suite en revanche si on la trouve on
vous l'enverra et elle figurera je pense
dans notre état de lieu que nous
publierons en novembre
s'agissant des différentes
différences on va pouvoir vous envoyer
aussi des éléments et je pense que ça
fera le lien avec votre question
également madame la rapporteur
s'agissant du réseau UNICEF en effet
nous avons un réseau vilaine des enfants
que nous travaillons à chaque nouvelle
édition donc qui correspond au mandat
avec la volonté d'accompagner toujours
plus les villes vers l'effectivité des
droits de l'enfant sur leur territoire
aujourd'hui nous avons des villes de La
Réunion qui sont membres du réseau
vitamines des enfants évidemment en même
temps que nous progressons en matière de
plaidoyer sur les territoires
ultramarins l'idée c'est vraiment aussi
de pouvoir de plus en plus travailler
avec les collectivités localement donc
pour le moment ça se concentrait
essentiellement sur la Réunion mais nous
avons vraiment envie que ce soit
davantage lors du lors du prochain
mandat peut-être vous dire aussi que
nous travaillons actuellement sur un
dispositif qui s'appelle le dispositif
école ami des droits de l'enfant qui
vise notamment en fait à proposer une
école parler droit pour les droits
l'enfant enfin c'est toute une technique
que je vais pas forcément détailler ce
matin mais sur laquelle je pourrais vous
envoyer des éléments et l'idée aussi
c'est que certaines de ces écoles de
cette méthodologie puissent aussi
concerner des écoles dans les
territoires ultramarins on espère
notamment en Guyane puisque ça permet
notamment de mieux connaître les droits
de l'enfance qui on se rend compte n'est
pas toujours bien le cas partout on a
également un comité local à la Réunion
donc voilà c'est une façon aussi de
renforcer progressivement notre notre
action
s'agissant du regard que nous avons sur
la coordination entre les différents
acteurs il sera difficile pour nous d'en
dire davantage que concernant la Guyane
puisque je viens travailler surtout sur
la Guyane ce qui est bon signe c'est
qu'on voit que la collectivité
territoriale de Guyane ainsi que le
rectorat travaille bien ensemble donc
sur le sujet de l'éducation c'est une
très bonne chose ça a permis notamment
de relancer cet observatoire de la
scolarisation et de la réussite
éducative dont nous parlions un peu plus
tôt et on espère vraiment que cette
dynamique va se poursuivre notamment sur
les autres sujets qui sont des sujets
qui restent
problématiques notamment les questions
de transport les questions enfin les
transports coûtent cher les transports
ne sont pas toujours pratiques donc pour
les enfants c'est un vrai sujet quand il
s'agit de faire trois heures de pirogue
pour aller à l'école disons que ça ne
facilite pas forcément à l'assiduité
d'autres questions qui se posent
également par exemple s'agissant de on
le disait tout à l'heure du manque
d'internat on sait qu'il y a un travail
qui est fait pour renforcer les
propositions en internat mais pour le
moment dispositif comme le dispositif
des familles hébergentes nous semblent
pas satisfaisants en l'état donc voilà
on sait que en tout cas il y a une
attention il y a un travail ensemble
mais c'est vrai que peut-être ce qui
manque et ça je pense que ça pourrait
être confirmé dans notre dans notre état
des lieux c'est que à notre sens les
droits de l'enfant ne sont pas toujours
vraiment mises au centre de ces
politiques publiques là donc évidemment
nous c'est le enfin chacun est dans son
rôle et nous c'est évidemment ce qu'on
porte mais disons que parfois il
faudrait peut-être un peu renforcer la
question des droits de l'enfant et
peut-être adapter certaines politiques
pour pour s'assurer de l'effectivité des
droits de l'enfant et je pense que c'est
notamment certaines enfin l'une des
réponses que l'on peut faire s'agissant
de Mayotte j'entends bien qu'il y a des
difficultés sur place mais notre rôle
c'est aussi d'essayer de proposer des
recommandations qui feraient en sorte
d'assurer l'effectivité des droits des
enfants le plus possible nous sommes
dans notre rôle et après évidemment nous
ne sommes pas en position de législateur
mais en tout cas ce qu'on peut dire
c'est regarder les regarder la situation
et dire quelle est son impact sur la
réalisation des droits des enfants et
c'est pour ça qu'on se permet de faire
un certain nombre de recommandations
tout en sachant qu'après voilà nous ne
sommes pas le législateur
peut-être que sur l'observatoire de
l'annonce scolarisation puisque j'en
disais quelques mots c'est des
discussions qu'on a aussi au niveau
national qui enfin avec avec les
ministères c'est des discussions qui
avancent bien donc on pourra aussi vous
en dire davantage puisque on espère
notamment que ce dispositif puisse
figurer soit dans Le Pacte des
solidarités soit dans le comité
interministériel qui est pilotée par par
madame la secrétaire d'État Charlotte
cobel donc voilà on continue vraiment à
pousser ce dispositif parce qu'il nous
semble que ça doit vraiment être regardé
à l'échelle de la France tout entière et
si possible comme je le disais
harmoniser aussi les méthodologies
je sais pas si tu voulais prendre je
vais
oui merci beaucoup je vais me permettre
de répondre à monsieur le sénateur mais
on pourra prendre un autre temps pour
pour évoquer toutes ces questions qui
demandent quand même beaucoup de
réflexion mais je serai très preneuse
d'évoquer avec vous la réforme de la
nationalité
peut-être sur les classes itinérantes
vous avez raison ce dispositif ne
prévoit pas spécifiquement la
scolarisation des enfants étrangers bien
heureusement
nous on a juste analysé aussi les
décisions de justice qui ont été prises
en ce sens également le les décisions de
la Défenseur des droits qui fait état
dans l'effectivité des droits puisqu'on
parlait d'effectivité des droits qui
fait état d'un
manque d'égalité entre les enfants de
nationalité française et les enfants
considérés comme étrangers mais bien
évidemment on sait très bien que le
dispositif de classes itinérante qui est
un dispositif actuellement qui peut
permettre de répondre à certains besoins
on sait très bien qu'il vaut pour tout
le monde et que l'annonce scolarisation
concerne tous les enfants sur le
territoire de Mayotte
peut-être sur l'accès à la nationalité
comme je vous le disais ça demanderait
des conseils des réflexions plus
approfondies
je vais me permettre de reprendre votre
votre terme vous disiez que la réforme
est de la niote les conseils
selon certains voilà
mais les conséquences sur la réalisation
des droits de l'enfant elle est
enfin elle est quand même assez
dramatique enfin vous le savez je vous
apprends rien mais la composition des
familles à Mayotte comprend parfois
plusieurs statues avec des enfants de
nationalité française des enfants qui
n'ont pas la nationalité française et en
fait après cette réforme il y a des
milliers d'enfants qui se sont retrouvés
du jour au lendemain pensant depuis leur
naissance qu'ils allaient devenir
français ils ont étudié ils ont été
scolarisés dans le système de droit
commun français ils se sont retrouvés
sans la possibilité d'obtenir la
nationalité française donc ça engendre
de fait des conséquences sur la
poursuite de leurs études par exemple
mais également leur intergration au sein
au sein de la République française mais
on pourra en parler oui
les dispositions sont impliquées depuis
2018 donc c'est impossible qu'elle
puisse toucher des personnes un voie de
scolarisation il y a une rétroactivité
de la de la loi qui est prévue
les élèves qui ont 18 et plus ne sont
pas touchés par cette réforme et
pourtant il y a ce problème qui est réel
que vous soulignez mais il y a un
principe de ré-autres rétroactivité de
la loi qui s'applique actuellement pour
les enfants qui viennent d'avoir 18 ans
le plus loin qu'on puisse remonter c'est
2013 donc 2013 à 2023 c'est 10 ans ça
touche quand même certains en tout cas
une partie des enfants qui ont qui ont
18 ans aujourd'hui enfin même depuis
a priori il y a un point de désaccord
important moi je pense vous propose je
pense que il faudra vraiment nous
préciser les choses
sénateur voilà vie à Mayotte représente
le territoire de Mayotte donc forcément
il y a une discussion une
oui oui tout à fait je comprends tout à
fait donc j'ai été juriste en accès au
droit à Mayotte et j'ai pu accompagner
aussi des jeunes dans l'axe à leur
nationalité c'est de enfin les deux
dernières années donc on pourra discuter
de vision et de voilà position
extrêmement différente chacun affirme
donc bien entendu ça mérite des
discussions à tout à fait plus longues
et des précisions évidemment donc on le
fera dans les échanges que nous pourrons
avoir ensemble je vous remercie et je
vous laisse poursuivre oui par contre je
vous rejoins sur la circulaire tobira
qui est effectivement une réflexion qui
est intéressante et pertinente mais qui
s'appliquent pas notamment à Mayotte ça
c'est aussi une conséquence du système
dérogatoire puisque comme comme vous le
savez lorsqu'on obtient un titre de
séjour à Mayotte c'est un titre de
séjour territorialisé qui ne permet pas
de se déplacer librement sur l'ensemble
du territoire français il faut que les
personnes puissent solliciter un visa et
ça va aussi pour les documents de
circulation pour étranger mineur c'est
la même chose il faut que l'enfant en
plus soit né sur le territoire donc ça
c'est une des conséquences effectivement
du système dérogatoire et si on permet
justement aux personnes qui ont un titre
de séjour mais également aux enfants
quand un document de circulation de
pouvoir circuler librement la circulaire
Taubira pourrait aussi s'appliquer et
permettrait également enfin ça demande
des réflexions mais c'est un levier qui
pourrait être
potentiellement intéressant et pertinent
et peut-être sur les actions aux Comores
et je vais donc juste peut-être conclure
avec en effet les actions que nous avons
comment puisque nous avons un bureau
UNICEF aux Comores qui mène un certain
nombre d'actions d'ailleurs on pourra
vous envoyer si vous voulez les éléments
sur sur leur programme avec alors pas
forcément l'idée de fixer les
populations parce que c'est vrai que
c'est en soi des actions de
développement comme nous avons dans tous
les autres
dans tous les autres pays dans des
situations similaires mais je pourrais
vous envoyer des éléments et d'ailleurs
nous sommes régulièrement en contact
avec eux donc on peut aussi tout à fait
je pense globalement rediscuter aussi de
ces sujets là ensemble notamment parce
que comme on espère pouvoir travailler
davantage sur les sujets qui concernent
Mayotte évidemment ce sera avec plaisir
qu'on pourra travailler ensemble
j'espère
merci beaucoup mesdames et merci pour
votre engagement pour ces territoires
ultramarins vous autres intervention
s'inscrivait dans nos travaux sur la
parentalité dans les territoires
ultramarins comme vous le voyez nous
avons des sénateurs qui représentent ces
territoires dans la délégation et qui
porte aussi leur convictions et donc on
attend avec impatience bien entendu tous
les éléments auxquels vous apporter des
réponses et qu'on n'aura pas eu le temps
ce matin de d'évoquer merci à vous
Mesdames et nous allons poursuivre chers
collègues avec une autre audition la
Croix Rouge merci
du président Stéphane d'artano qui
préside la délégation au territoire
ultramarin la délégation outre-mer et
donc également des rapporteurs et des
collègues de la de nos délégations
respectives donc nous poursuivons nos
travaux sur la parentalité dans les
territoires d'outre-mer avec une
audition de la Croix-Rouge ce matin
après l'UNICEF donc nous accueillons
Gaëlle nerbach directrice nationale
outre-mer de la Croix-Rouge française
accompagné de Anne scrobot je n'ai pas
écorché votre nom c'est très bien
directrice adjointe de la direction
nationale outre-mer et de Madame Alizée
bombardier responsable relation
institutionnelle et développement de
projets et bien bienvenue à vous
mesdames merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation la Croix-Rouge française est
la seule association à avoir une
couverture nationale complète en
métropole et dans chaque territoire
d'outre-mer avec
3700 volontaires engagé dans les douze
délégations territoriales
ultramarines elle a donc une vision
transversale des difficultés rencontrées
par les publics qu'elle accompagne et
des caractéristiques propres à chaque
territoire nos attentes s'articulent
autour de plusieurs axes que je vais
vous expliquer donc d'abord connaître
les actions menées par la Croix Rouge
dans les territoires outre-mer et savoir
comment vous adaptez vos missions
d'action sociale à ces territoires
davantage touchés par la précarité en
particulier précarité des mères seuls
l'annonce colorisation le décrochage
scolaire des jeunes les grossesses
Périclès ou encore la présence de
mineurs non accompagnée en grande
difficulté deuxièmement nous souhaitons
connaître les recommandations de la
Croix Rouge afin d'améliorer la
situation des familles d'outre-mer à
travers nos travaux nous sommes à la
recherche de solutions d'outils pour que
nos politiques familiales et sociales
tiennent davantage compte des
particularités
ultramarines
et pour améliorer le soutien à la
parentalité dans ces territoires
ultramarins donc je vais vous laisser
sans tarder la parole madame Gaëlle
nerba et ensuite nous aurons un temps
d'échange je rappelle vous êtes
directrice nationale outre-mer de la
Croix-Rouge française merci Madame
d'être là et à vous vous appuyez sur le
bouton lorsque vous parlez et vous
l'éteignez lorsque vous ne parlez pas le
bouton de gauche voilà très bien merci
bonjour à toutes et tous madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président
Mesdames les rapporteurs
mesdames les sénatrices mesdames
messieurs pardon les sénateurs merci de
nous accueillir aujourd'hui pour vous
présenter une thématique importante pour
la Croix-Rouge française qui est la
parentalité en outre-mer avant d'entrer
dans le vif de sujet je vais vous
rappeler rapidement
ce qu'est la Croix Rouge en outre-mer
vous présentez les dispositifs ensuite
d'aide à parentalité que nous avons sur
les territoires
avant de venir au constat et que nous au
constat que nous faisons au sein de nos
dispositifs
alors mon côté normalement il y a une
présentation qui va s'afficher j'ai fait
un petit internet
pour que la présentation s'affiche une
petite chanson où je peux commencer si
vous pouvez commencer vous pouvez
commencer mais je pense que comme la
l'audition est sur le site du Sénat ça
serait bien que ça se connecte mais il
semble que ce soit la technique du Sénat
qui soit
responsable de la mise en route
ah sur le diffuser sur le site alors si
c'est difficile sur le site vous pouvez
continuer madame et on vous écoute avec
attention très bien merci madame la
Présidente comme vous le rappeliez en
effet la Croix-Rouge française est
la seule association nationale à être
présente dans les trois océans en
outre-mer ce qui nous donne une
visibilité des territoires mais aussi
une connaissance particulière à 360
degrés de ce qui s'y passe sur un
certain nombre de sujets donc nous
sommes un auxiliaire d'épouvoirs publics
reconnus et un acteur de confiance
12 délégations territoriales c'est 51
établissements
des directions territoriales également
et plus de 3700 bénévoles comme vous le
disiez une particularité que nous avons
en outre-mer nous disposons de trois
plateformes d'intervention
révisionnelles qui interviennent dans
les zones et les bassins régionaux en
matière de sensibilisation et de gestion
des risques catastrophes naturelles
quatre thématiques ont été
définies prio comme prioritaire pour la
Croix-Rouge en outre-mer la prévention
en gestion des crises comme vous savez
nous les y sommes soumis crise sociale
mais crise climatique surtout un enjeu
majeur du Bien Vieillir malheureusement
et la crise sanitaire nous l'a montré
que les violences intra-familiales sont
très présentes et concernent l'ensemble
des territoires
ultramarins et le sujet de la jeunesse
et est aussi une priorité sans entrer
dans le détail des différentes
dispositifs peut-être vous dire que la
Croix-Rouge française et la Croix-Rouge
française en outre-mer est une
association généraliste
donc nous couvrons en spectre très
important qui va de la prise en charge
de la petite enfance avec des crèches
des dispositifs d'aide à la parentalité
auprès des familles des maisons
d'enfants à caractère social en matière
de protection de l'enfance nous avons
également les seules dispositifs de
prévention spécialisés que nous
retrouvons à Mayotte à Saint-Barthélémy
et en Nouvelle-Calédonie
et nous allons jusqu'à la campagnement
des personnes âgées avec des EHPAD des
résidences autonomiques ou encore des
services de soins à domicile
je vais maintenant vous présenter nos
dispositifs par territoire relatifs à
l'accompagnement des enfants et des
familles
peut-être
rappeler que pour nous
l'accompagnement est basé sur le
volontariat évidemment des familles
et que c'est une donnée essentielle et
que la cible de
des personnes que nous ont accompagnons
sont certes les parents
des parents vulnérables
vulnérables on va y revenir c'est un
sujet majeur les vulnérabilités en ce
qui concerne les familles et vous allez
voir que c'est une porte d'entrée donc
on n'arrive pas à la question de l'aide
à parler en réalité
tout de suite il y a quand même la
nécessité de prendre en charge les
autres difficultés que rencontre les
parents
et cela paraît essentiel
alors
sur la donc en Martinique nous disposons
de plusieurs
dispositifs
nous avons des lieux de soutien à la
parentalité à Saint-Pierre à
Fort-de-France et à Sainte-Luce
des espaces rencontres parents enfants
nous faisons aussi nous organisons des
stages de rappel à responsabilité
parentale lorsque des décisions lorsque
des parents en effet ont eu
malheureusement des gestes et donc nous
travaillons sur la récidive par rapport
à ses comportements
et nous avons également des appartements
thérapeutiques où nous accompagnons des
enfants qui rencontrent des pathologies
assez lourdes comme le cancer et nous
accompagnons donc les familles dans ce
cadre là au sein de ces appartements
j'aimerais juste présenter rapidement
l'option Croix Rouge qui a qui est un
dispositif national porté par la
Croix-Rouge française
au sein de tous les territoires et
évidemment les outre-mer et dans ce
cadre nous intervenons au sein des
collèges école lycée université nos
bénévoles interviennent pour travailler
avec les équipes éducatives sur une
thématique définie par elle cela peut
donc un exemple là au collège dans un
des collèges sur à Fort-de-France il
s'agit de travailler avec un EHPAD sur
le lien interagénérationnel donc avec
des travaux menés dans au sein d'un
jardin de générationnel comment cultiver
retrouver la culture de certains légumes
que certains
enfants aujourd'hui ont oublié et c'est
un dispositif extrêmement intéressant et
très soutenu et nous en sommes très très
fiers et c'est aussi un moyen de
travailler
tout un tas de sujets avec avec les
jeunes
à Saint-Martin donc nous disposons d'une
crèche d'une d'une crèche Pomme d'Api
qui a la particularité
d'accueillir une 12aine d'enfants
en situation de handicap donc au sein de
ces dispositifs évidemment nous
travaillons également avec les familles
nous avons un espace santé jeune qui
travaille sur la santé sexuelle les
addictions auprès des jeunes et dans ce
cadre-là des ateliers sont organisés
aussi au sein des établissements
scolaires donc avec les équipes
éducatives vous nous avons des activités
sur ces questions santé sexuelles
addiction avec les familles
à Saint-Barthélémy
depuis donc nous avons signé cette année
une convention avec la collectivité pour
mettre en place un dispositif de
prévention spécialisée et ce qui cater
caractérise en général mais j'y
reviendrai là
la Croix Rouge c'est de le développement
de de dispositif d'aller vers vraiment
nous allons vers le public les publics
que nous accompagnons et donc ce
dispositif en est un exemple évidemment
du soutien scolaire et l'option Croix
Rouge et aussi mise en place à
Saint-Barth avec d'autres dispositifs de
vestiboutiques c'était lieux où les
personnes viennent en fait les
dispositifs de la Croix-Rouge sont
surtout des lieux de rencontres c'est à
dire nous sommes là pour remettre en
place le lien social on parle beaucoup
d'isolement les crises la crise
sanitaire nous a montré à quel point nos
populations sont isolées et se rendre
dans la vestiboutique pour un café ou
pour venir acheter un vêtement permet
aussi d'aborder tout un tas de sujets
autour de la personne accompagnée
en Guyane nous avons des un espace
parents enfants et nous donc comme vous
le savez nous donc cet espace parents
enfant se trouve à Cayenne il est ouvert
aux parents d'enfants âgés de moins de
18 mois et ce sont des familles en
grande en situation de précarité
et donc ces ateliers s'organisent une
fois par semaine et ce qu'on voit c'est
que ça répond vraiment à un besoin de
disposer de structures innovantes pour
les parents en situation de grande
précarité en Guyane comme ailleurs mais
ayant ce dispositif on peut le confirmer
l'objectif de ce dispositif et d'aider
les familles de permettre d'envisager un
avenir évidemment meilleur et ce sont
les bénévoles de la Croix-Rouge qui
porte ce dispositif
objectifs comme je l'ai dit c'est de
d'accompagner les les parents dans leur
rôle de mère de père retrouver aussi le
plaisir d'échanger parce que parfois il
y a des ruptures de liens au sein des
familles et nous faisons également de la
distribution de les médicalisés
d'urgence à la demande évidemment des
professionnels de santé qui nous
envoient les familles concernées
[Musique]
à la réunion nous disposons d'une maison
d'enfants à caractère social et nous
faisons également de la médiation
sociale de rue avec de grâce un
dispositif aussi là d'aller vers alors
pourquoi nous avons mis la maison
d'enfants caractères social l'aide
d'appel à la rentabilité intrinsèque à
ce dispositif nous accueillons des
enfants donc placés par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance et nous avons au sein de ce
dispositif un travail important fait
avec évidemment les familles à la fois à
l'occasion donc évidemment de de visites
organisée mais des ateliers également
sont réalisés avec les familles
[Musique]
à Mayotte
nous disposons d'une Maison des familles
qui a un dispositif récent il ne date
que de l'année dernière mais nous voyons
tous les jours à quel point il est
indispensable
on a les familles donc il se trouve à
Passins Monti les familles viennent
rencontrer nos équipes pour des ateliers
avec
avec les enfants des jeux mais c'est
aussi l'occasion d'aborder un ensemble
de sujets et de difficultés qui peuvent
rencontrer ce que nous constatons dans
ce dispositif c'est que
pour pouvoir en général pour pouvoir
travailler avec les parents et les
familles il faut travailler sur les
autres difficultés qu'il rencontre
précarité alimentaire
on constate aussi mais pas qu'à Mayotte
la difficulté parfois sur comment dire
le
comment dire l'électro est un sujet
aussi vous savez à l'école tout est à
l'école collège ou lycée tout est envoyé
aujourd'hui
par internet
les difficultés de lecture etc peuvent
rencontrer comment dire mettre en
difficulté les familles et nous nous
travaillons avec elle justement pour
leur permettre de retrouver leur place
de parents c'est à dire si voilà les
difficultés psychologiques les
difficultés liées à la précarité
alimentaire et donc la chance que nous
avons à la Croix-Rouge c'est de d'être
généraliste et de proposer l'ensemble de
ces dispositifs et donc on peut
travailler ensuite sur la parentalité en
tant que tel nous vous disposons d'un
service de lutte contre la malnutrition
infantile où nous intervenons donc à
l'intérieur des villages et des
quartiers sur la question de la
nutrition infantile et un autre
dispositif qui
qu'on appelle hidis box c'est un
dispositif de la de bibliothèque sans
frontières qui est une box numérique qui
nous permet d'accéder travailler sur la
lecture le numérique et également donc
ce dispositif en aller vers nous allons
dans les quartiers dans les villages là
où la population a besoin de nous
en Nouvelle-Calédonie nous avons deux
crèches
donc de crèche la maison du petit enfant
les cerisiers bleus elle se trouve à
Nouméa la particule
la particularité Nouvelle-Calédonie
c'est qu'il y a la Nouvelle-Calédonie
dispose de très peu de crèches et elles
sont en partie concentrées concentré
autour de Nouméens et nous avons nous
grâce à nos partenaires la possibilité à
la Croix-Rouge donc il y a très peu de
crèches associatives les autres crèches
sont privés donc elles sont concentrées
à Nouméa et l'intérêt pour nous c'est de
proposer différents tarifs peu de
crèches proposent différents tarifs nous
nous pouvons le faire donc on a quatre
cas quatre tarifs pour les familles
comme vous le savez la
Nouvelle-Calédonie n'a pas le même
système que dans le reste du territoire
et cela permet de prendre en charge des
familles aussi en situation de
vulnérabilité au sein de ces crèches
nous travaillons évidemment sur des
ateliers avec les familles et on a un
autre dispositif qui accompagne cela la
Maison des familles de la famille où
nous organisons des ateliers également
autour de l'aide à la parentalité
pourquoi avoir parlé la Prévention
Spécialisée la médiation sociale parce
qu'on voit à quel point dans ce
dispositif les jeunes que nous
accompagnons
donc on ne nous accompagnons des jeunes
et nous voyons à quel point les familles
sont peut-être éloignées de
l'accompagnement parce que aussi
rencontrons d'autres difficultés
alimentaires
des addictions malheureusement qui les
empêchent peut-être de prendre ce rôle
de de parents et au sein de la au sein
de la Nouvelle-Calédonie nous
travaillons aussi beaucoup à la fois en
établissement scolaire mais en aller
vers sur la lutte contre différents
types d'addiction
le constat général sur les structures
familiales que
mesdames laissaient natrices et les
sénateurs connaissent évidemment mais ce
que je vais dire là est
un constat que nous faisons au sein des
dispositifs qui n'est pas limitatif mais
concerne ce que les salariés les
bénévoles constatent dans leur
accompagnement
évidemment une grande part de famille
monoparentale
qui qui concerne les territoires donc
monoparentale parce que il y a souvent
des pères il peut y avoir des pères mais
les pères souvent ne reconnaissent pas
les enfants
on constate également
des situations de couple hors habitation
conjugale c'est-à-dire que beaucoup de
familles et on le constate en Martinique
mais pas seulement
des familles qui
ne vivent pas ensemble
le père n'est pas présent au sein au
sein au sein de la famille donc dans la
quasi-totalité des cas de séparations
l'enfant est vie évidemment avec sa mère
et
être très peu de pourquoi une des
raisons on s'explique par le fait que
très peu de famille en recours à la
justice pour organiser la garde d'enfant
nous constatons également que la
présence du père est très forte parce
que c'est lui c'est le père qui décide
des rythmes de visite des rythmes de
sortie les rythmes sans reconnaissance
on va dire par ailleurs mais c'est la
place il prend cette place là
alors que la mère conserve le rôle
éducatif et économique
j'ai parlé du modèle de de on parle de
modèle de famille mais la famille
élargie
est un sujet également c'est le cas en
Nouvelle-Calédonie
et aux Antilles même si ça tend à
évoluer c'est à dire que au sein d'une
famille
la famille c'est pas le père la mère et
l'enfant il peut on peut se retrouver à
plusieurs générations dans une même
habitation donc cohabitation dans un
même lieu c'est fortement le cas en
Nouvelle-Calédonie ce qu'on constatant
c'était le cas en Martinique on le voit
que cela évolue avec le départ des
jeunes qui est un vrai sujet comme vous
le savez
dans nous constatons également
l'influence évidente du de la famille
élargit sur l'éducation des enfants et
que l'appartenance sociale est
évidemment un facteur déterminant
en Martinique plus de la moitié des
structures familiales avec enfants donc
je le disais
son monoparental
et peut-être préciser que dans le cas
des familles monoparentales on peut
distinguer les couples séparés les
couples hors cohabitation conjugale
voilà
et en tout cas merci j'ai essayé d'être
synthétique mais je suis disponible pour
répondre à vos questions
peut-être
ajouter et compléter sur le fait que ce
que nous faisons comme constat c'est
qu'il y a un certain nombre de le sujet
de la parentalité est traité en
outre-mer mais sous la forme de grands
colloque de grandes conférences ce n'est
pas de cette façon à notre sens que ce
sujet peut être abordé par rapport aux
familles que nous accompagnons il est
important peut-être
je veux dire on retrouve dans ces
colloques et des conférences des
personnes très intéressantes qui
connaissent le sujet mais pas forcément
le public que nous souhaitons toucher
il faut aussi éviter de stigmatiser nos
familles qui ont une qui ont le qui
peuvent avoir un sentiment de jugement
au sens où la parentalité de l'ordre de
personnel d'une histoire
il constate en effet une méfiance très
importante sur les nouvelles pratiques
éducatives comme vous le savez
malheureusement nous constatons et je
l'ai dit en introduction de nombreuses
de encore trop souvent des violences
éducatives ordinaires qui sont au centre
de l'éducation
des familles et donc cette remise en
cause
est difficile c'est pour cette raison
que nous abordons le sujet différemment
et on va y revenir et que et c'est
peut-être une un des premiers constats
que nous faisons l'aide à la parentalité
il y a des dispositifs mais pour nous
c'est un dispositif qui doit être
transversal à l'ensemble des dispositifs
que la Croix-Rouge porte c'est à dire
que la première porte d'entrée peut être
la précarité alimentaire lorsque la
famille vient nous rencontrer pour pour
l'aide alimentaire souvent
on peut voilà on peut parler d'autres
sujets et le sujet de l'enfant de la
famille arrive après et même lorsque
nous avons des dispositifs que comme des
lieux de ressources parentalité en
Martinique ça va pas être une première
question nous allons pas traiter le
sujet en tête à tête avec la famille
pour pastigmatiser la mettre en
difficulté donc c'est des ateliers
collectifs
ils vont parler leur difficulté et la
question de l'enfant et la de
l'éducation arrivera après et c'est
comme ça que nous apportons le sujet
c'est vraiment important de en tout cas
c'est un constat qu'on fait que les
dispositifs aujourd'hui doivent être
transversaux et qu'avant de traiter la
question de la parentalité nous devons
agir sur l'ensemble des vulnérabilités
que
rencontre les familles
de plus et de et malheureusement les
familles que nous accompagnons et la
crise la montrer en contre des
difficultés alimentaires
et que c'est le premier sujet si vous
avez aussi vous rencontrez ces
difficultés c'était on ne peut pas
travailler en vacances qui n'a pas mangé
qui doit régler ses factures et qui ne
sait pas le faire etc il n'est pas
disponible pour l'éducation donc nous
travaillons sur l'ensemble de ces
vulnérabilités merci
merci Madame la Directrice pour vous
pouvez éteindre votre micro s'il vous
plaît merci donc merci Madame la
Directrice pour ces propos et ses
explications donc je vais sans plus
tarder laisser la parole au rapporteur
au sénateur et sénatrices qui souhaitent
interroger vous interroger en tant que
organisation présente dans tous les
territoires ultramarins la Croix Rouge
et donc je passe tout de suite la parole
au président Stéphane et rapporteur
Stéphane Artano
merci madame la Présidente Directrice
mesdames
d'abord félicitations pour votre
implantation surtout outre-mer je pense
qu'il faut quand même le dire parce que
vous êtes un acteur un acteur majeur et
vous rayonnez surtout nos territoire et
justement je voulais savoir si par
rapport à l'approche transversale sur la
parentalité que vous évoquez à laquelle
je souscris si parce qu'on voit bien que
le déploiement de la Croix-Rouge est
différent en fonction des territoires
est-ce que c'est lié à l'histoire de
l'implantation de la Croix-Rouge sur ces
territoires est-ce que c'est lié à des
constats opérés sur les territoires
est-ce que c'est lié au moyen financiers
dont vous disposez on va on va aller
dans le dur est-ce que c'est lié à des
choix entre guillemets politiques
d'orientation de l'action de la Croix
Rouge et en l'occurrence si vous parlez
d'approche transversale est-ce que il y
a une volonté de d'avoir cette approche
transversale sur l'ensemble des
territoires ou est-ce que vous plaidez
pour une approche un peu territorialisée
merci monsieur le Président si vous le
permettez Madame la Directrice je vais
prendre toutes les questions je pense
que c'est plus efficace dans ce cas là
si vous pouvez noter les questions et
puis on y répondra comme ça de j'ai vu
que tous les collègues se sont inscrits
donc je vais faire dans l'ordre
de la table donc la rapporteur elles
achalke merci madame la Présidente à mon
tour de vous remercier pour pour votre
présentation et pour vous féliciter pour
votre action
au quotidien pour votre présence
effectivement sur l'ensemble de
territoires et du coup pour votre
expertise et la connaissance que vous en
avez on sait bien et on mesure à quel
point la Croix-Rouge française est un
acteur majeur et un acteur aussi de
confiance et comme vous l'avez dit avec
une mission finalement qui est très
large pas centré sur la parentalité en
fait à la base mais plus sur une
prévention une gestion effectivement de
risques même de conflits et pour autant
vous vous investissez et on voit très
bien à travers les différents
dispositifs et outils que vous nous avez
présenté sur les territoires à la fois
que vous êtes présent mais également que
vous faites preuve aussi de d'adaptation
en fonction des territoires et du coup
ma question rejoindra celle du président
Stéphane Artano est-ce que enfin comment
vous mettez en fait en place les
différents outils et les différents
dispositifs puisqu'on voit que une fois
il y a l'idée d'une crèche une fois une
distribution de les médicalisés donc ça
peut être très divers et très large dans
l'émission est-ce que c'est les acteurs
locaux qui vous sollicitent en disant
bah il y a un besoin et voilà sur quels
sont les outils dont on aurait besoin
est-ce que c'est les collectivités
territoriales les élus locaux comment ça
s'explique alors mon collègue Stéphane
Artano évoqué l'histoire les moyens
financiers euh mais est-ce que il y a
aussi une approche plus particulière par
rapport à remonter aussi que vous font
les familles dans un autre cadre lorsque
vous les voyez effectivement pour toutes
les actions que vous avez évoqué voilà
merci beaucoup merci Madame la
rapporteur la rapporteur victoire jasmin
qui connaît bien son territoire de
Guadeloupe et les territoires aux
alentours merci beaucoup la présidente
présidente ainsi que toutes les
personnes qui vous accompagnent vous
remercient pour votre présence et pour
quasiment l'exhaustivité des travaux que
vous mener sur l'ensemble des
territoires
concernant les crèches parce que c'est
important sur le territoire il y a pas
suffisamment de crèches lors de nos
déplacements nous avons constaté qu'il y
avait vraiment des carences à certains
endroits et je voudrais savoir quels
sont les critères concernant les tarifs
vous avez ok qu'il y avait des tarifs
différenciés alors est-ce qu'il y a des
critères parce que les personnes
travaillent ou pas qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire là-dessus concernant
également tout ce qui concerne la
prévention la prévention et la vue sur
l'alimentation vous avez vu sur cette
territoire en fonction des besoins alors
vous adaptez votre façon de appréhender
sur chaque territoire mais en fonction
des besoins que vous constatez c'est pas
c'est de façon différente vous ne faites
pas les mêmes choses au même endroit sur
chacun des territoires voilà donc c'est
un fonction des différents territoires
et puis les relations avec les
collectivités locales
comment ça se traduit concrètement
est-ce qu'ils sont qui vous sollicitent
ou est-ce que vous c'est vous qui faites
la démarche et avec les familles aussi
le choix des familles et les
applications les autres acteurs comme la
CAF la PMI avec les autres acteurs qui
sont identifiés les conseils
départementaux
voilà comment vous travaillez avec ces
différents partenaires merci beaucoup
merci Madame la rapporteur le sénateur
de Mayotte d'animaux elle soit liées à
vous la parole chers collègues merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente moi
j'aurais une question avant cela je
voudrais me joindre au loin je de Elsa
par rapport à l'action de la Croix-Rouge
dans dans nos territoires il y a
beaucoup de pragmatisme et de
professionnalisme
en plus c'est une association qui
militante et qui se contente de faire
de faire le boulot pour lequel elle sait
elle s'est engagée et ça fait plaisir ça
aide d'un dans ces territoires néanmoins
je vais poser une question qui peut
paraître un peu politique mais
Gaëlle nerbach qui connaît très bien
Mayotte je pense pour un pourra y
répondre et est-ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression que la non-application de
l'aide médicale d'État à Mayotte
limite encore plus l'accès aux soins
c'est un sujet c'est un serpent de mer
tous les rapports ont préconisé la mise
en place de l'aide médicale d'État et
pourtant on nous dit ça va faire un
appel d'air et moi je dis souvent
l'heure n'est plus à l'appel d'air la
pelle d'air est derrière nous on est à
un stade après après l'appel d'air donc
la réponse est dans ma question mais
est-ce que vous dans la pratique vous
n'avez pas l'impression que cette non
application qui grève les crédits déjà
mince des hôpitaux enfin de de l'hôpital
et des dispensaires freinent encore plus
l'accès aux soins merci merci monsieur
le sénateur de Mayotte on va passer
maintenant à la Guyane avec notre
collègue Marie-Laure Pinera horte vous
voyez les territoires sont très bien
représentés ce matin merci présidente
alors c'est vrai que Madame la
Directrice générale ça vaut une petite
discussion dans les couloirs parce que
vous étiez en avance mais ça ne
m'empêche pas de vous poser de questions
d'abord vous dire que en Guyane et à
Mayotte nous avons ce défi qui est
l'immigration clandestine et
malheureusement les femmes et les
enfants sont souvent victimes des pires
atrocités sur les routes migratoires ces
enfants reçoivent un accompagnement
notamment lorsqu'ils sont parcours de
scolarisation mais ce n'est pas
suffisant et cela contribue fortement à
l'échec scolaire aussi j'aimerais savoir
si la Croix Rouge a des préconisations
afin d'accompagner ses parents étrangers
et j'ai une deuxième question suite à
votre présentation je constate d'après
votre présentation que la Guyane n'est
pas dotée de crèche Croix-Rouge Maison
des familles prévention des addictions
ma question est la suivante à quand le
rééquilibrage de nos territoires voilà
merci merci chers collègues et enfin une
dernière question de notre collègue un
peu moins ultramarin pardon Marc laminy
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente et
puis merci pour le travail collectif que
je partage avec l'ensemble des collègues
et des deux délégations je crois que
bon c'est vrai je ne connais pas du tout
je suis jamais monsieur jamais rendu en
territoire
ultramarin mais je crois que c'est aussi
une non voilà non c'est ça c'est ça
c'est vrai mais je voyage grâce à mes
collègues je crois que c'est ça le plus
important qui connaissent bien alors bon
là c'est vrai que la Croix Rouge Madame
la directrice et mesdames qui
représentait la Croix Rouge je dirais
c'est une grande institution alors vous
avez cité le nombre de bénévoles alors
le nombre de bénévoles pour l'autre mère
et également le nombre de de
membres du personnel de salariés qui qui
sont sur le terrain pour l'outre-mer
pour voir un petit peu les effectifs ce
que cela représente puis également
bon il y a le volet humain qui est
prioritaire complètement mais
malheureusement tout est financier alors
je vais parler avec un peu ma casquette
de membre de la commission des finances
il y a le il y a la mission enfin sur le
budget de l'État parce que l'État quand
même reste le premier partenaire
financier
même vis-à-vis de l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales et vis-à-vis
des grandes structures des associations
aussi il y a la mission outre-mer et
donc il y a quand même des actions qui
qui apparaissent il y a le volet
éducation éducation nationale vous
l'avez aussi évoqué parce qu'il y a
quand même bon les crèches la petite
enfance le partage de génération
quels moyens parce que
il y a les collègues qui ont aussi
abordé le volet collectivité
territoriale quelle est l'action des
collectivités territoriales en outre-mer
l'action de l'Etat est-elle suffisante
et quels moyens
faudrait-il pour gérer améliorer les
choses bon de l'autre côté tout ce qui
est cruauté petit enfant il y a
les caisses de location familiales qui
interviennent également pour le volet
famille
mais bon là c'est un autre budget
sécurité sociale loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale
je dirais qu'est-ce qu'il manque puis en
plus à coup sûr vous travaillez aussi
avec d'autres associations et d'autres
structures d'autres partenaires
institutionnels les assistantes sociales
également enfin voilà il y a un petit
peu c'est une grande chaîne mais voilà
et mais sur le budget de l'État puisque
nous on est législateur qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait faire voilà merci beaucoup
merci chers collègues les questions
étaient nombreuses j'espère que vous les
avez bien
noté et on va vous laisser répondre et
vous organiser comme vous le souhaitez
si vous souhaitez en regrouper pour
faciliter la présentation vous n'hésitez
pas à vous Madame la Directrice
merci madame la Présidente je pense que
je vais répondre aux uns et aux autres
et
ça sera peut-être parfois regroupé parce
que certaines questions se rassemblaient
peut-être avant de commencer à répondre
moi aussi j'ai une petite frustration
parce que je ne vous ai pas présenté
l'ampleur en tout cas l'ensemble des
activités que nous réalisons je vous ai
rapidement brossé
nos interventions sur les territoires et
les champs d'intervention mais derrière
ce champ s'échange quand je vous parle
de la compagnement des personnages et
par exemple il y a plusieurs dispositifs
j'en ai cité mais en matière de lutte
contre l'exclusion il y a aussi des
Samus sociaux que nous avons
madame la sénatrice de Guyane nous avons
des centres de santé en Guyane mais
c'est vrai que je n'ai pas présent
présenter tous les dispositifs les
dispositifs de la Croix-Rouge sur les
territoires ne se résument pas à ces
dispositifs d'aide à parentalité mais je
pourrais vous transmettre des éléments
sur ce sujet pour répondre à votre
question monsieur le Président
en effet à quoi est dû l'implantation
des territoires je rappellerai peut-être
avant que la Croix Rouge
ne fait pas
de politique même si on est un outil
indispensable de politique sociale
et que nous sommes un opérateur
quel est le moyen de financement de la
Croix Rouge donc nous répondons à des
appels à projets nous répondons à donc
il y a on va dire sur
tous les territoires outre-mer exceptés
la
Pacifique Sud on va dire nous entrons
dans ce qu'on appelle des appels à
projet et donc la Croix-Rouge répond à
des appels à projets portés par la CAF
portée par la collectivité portée par
l'État porté par l'ARS et dans ce cadre
là les dispositifs sont créés à ce
moment là alors pourquoi avoir ouvert
une crèche à Saint-Martin ou en
Nouvelle-Calédonie des opportunités des
opportunités qui sont liées évidemment
aussi à notre capacité de réponse à un
moment donné mais force est de constater
aujourd'hui
que dans tout ce que nous faisons nous
voyons bien que la clé du sujet et
d'intervenir le plus tôt possible le
plus tôt possible c'est dès l'enfance
dès la petite enfance et les enfants ne
sont pas seuls il y a les familles et
donc nous pensons aujourd'hui que c'est
une priorité en tout cas pour la Croix
Rouge de développer des dispositifs
alors particulier reconnu comme les
lieux parentalités ressources comme les
maisons familles comme on a comme les la
Prévention Spécialisée parce que ça nous
amène aussi à travailler avec les
familles
il faut aller vers ça et notre rôle
d'opérateur essentiel et reconnu et
aussi d'alerte les pouvoirs publics mais
nous ne pouvons pas prendre l'initiative
de créer in situ une crèche si la
les comment dire les partenaires
responsables institutionnels n'en
prennent pas l'initiative nous sommes là
pour apporter une réponse mais mais nous
souhaitons nous développer sur ces
sujets
et nous souhaitons bien en développer
davantage madame la sénatrice de Guyane
sur sur la Guyane n'en doutez pas
et pourquoi pas Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon
mais
mais non on peut solliciter mais pour ce
faire évidemment monsieur le sénateur
les financements sont indispensables j'y
reviendrai à la fin de mon propos
pour donc c'est lié à l'histoire les
implantations aux moyens humains que
nous avions aussi et peut-être rappelé
que la Croix Rouge en outre-mer c'est
800 en effet salariés et plus de 3000
bénévoles et pourquoi nous parlons des
bénévoles et je tiens les saluer et les
salariés aussi et les rendre hommage
parce qu'ils font un formidable travail
et pas que c'est pas qu'un travail c'est
un engagement les salariés et les
bénévoles sont engagés c'est que
nous sommes et notre force est d'être
neutre nous regardons ni la couleur ni
d'où ils viennent ni nous nous prenons
en charge des hommes des femmes des
enfants vulnérables parce que en
difficulté nous les accompagnons et
voilà pourquoi la Croix-Rouge existe et
sa force tient au fait que nous nous
pouvons nous n'avons pas de
neutralité notre universalité univers
alité nous renforts
alors comment mettre en place les outils
et comment les acteurs locaux nous
sollicitent vous vous avez raison les
les collectivités peuvent et les caves
ou l'étape nous solliciter connaissance
notre
on va dire notre expérience sur le sujet
à Saint-Martin la PMI nous demande de
pourquoi pas ouvrir d'autres crèches ça
peut arriver mais
nous aussi nous pouvons proposer là
peut-être vous parler d'un projet
et peut-être que j'y vais revenir sur
sur la nécessité pour nous de
d'accompagner les jeunes mères on a
parlé de famille monoparentales donc il
s'agit surtout des jeunes femmes et et
le SMA le service militaire adapté comme
vous le savez
a été interpellé par le fait que les
volontaires de
sur les tarifs différenciés dont vous
avez parlé madame la sénatrice
jasmin
peut-être vous dire que le cas est
particulier en Nouvelle-Calédonie c'est
à dire que les la PSU n'existe pas
la PSU n'existe pas en
Nouvelle-Calédonie et il y a pas de il y
a quatre crèches associatives dont deux
de la Croix-Rouge à Nouméa et l'autre
elle est gérée par le CCAS de nouméen et
en ce qui nous concerne avec les
partenaires qui nous financent qui nous
financent à savoir la caisse la cafate
donc la caisse de sécurité sociale de de
nouvelles Calédonie
l'État et le CCAS de Nouméa nous pouvons
proposer ces tarifs différenciés la
demande est grande la demande est grande
et
malheureusement nous aimerions
faire plus et mieux mais nous n'avons
pas les financements
donc ça c'est pour le cas particulier de
la Nouvelle-Calédonie sinon sur le reste
du territoire ça s'applique la règle est
la même à savoir le financement par la
CAF des crèches néanmoins la difficulté
et vous connaissez très bien le sujet
c'est que nos crèches elles ont à
acheter des produits
à financer du personnel
et
donc les les salaires sont comme vous le
savez plus importants parce que nous
avons la prime de fichiers etc qui est
aussi intégré pour la Croix-Rouge pas
totalement mais en partie et ses coûts
supplémentaires ne sont pas forcément
intégrés dans la PSU alors monsieur le
sénateur qui me posait vous qui veut me
poser la question de savoir comment
vous parlementaire pouvait en effet agir
peut-être questionner la revoir la
question de la PSU en outre-mer et
prendre en compte l'ensemble de ces
spécificités parce que des opérateurs
comme nous voyons bien à quel point
cela peut l'être difficile au regard du
coup de fonctionnement d'une crèche et
là je parle pas forcément je veux dire
du compte de fonctionnement en général
avec les produits que nous devons en
effet à acheter et acquérir IR
très bien pardon je reprends
madame la sénatrice finira hors sur
l'accompagnement des parents étrangers
en Guyane
mais pas qu'en Guyane sur
c'est le cas aussi en Martinique parce
que nous avons c'est vrai qu'il a la
difficulté que j'ai c'est que j'ai pas
présenté notre dispositifs
d'accompagnement des demandeurs d'asile
par exemple que Madame la signatrice
connaît bien en Guyane maison nous en
avons aussi en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique et en tout
cas Mayotte la Croix-Rouge n'est pas
agréée pour accompagner les demandeurs
d'asile
sur sur les autres pardon
en revanche on n'est pas agréé mais nous
accueillons toutes les personnes
vulnérables sans regarder forcément le
statut sur donc nous nous avons des
dispositifs de lutte contre
l'illettrisme en fait
la force de la Croix Rouge et aussi
d'avoir des bénévoles qui vont faire du
[Musique]
de l'accompagnement scolaire de la lutte
contre l'illinitrice de la formation en
langue étrangère
j'ai oublié mais ça va revenir le flux
voilà et c'est ce travail est fait au
sein de dispositifs c'est-à-dire que on
les bénévoles vont organiser des temps
d'échanges avec les personnes en
situation irrégulière nous proposons
également nous avons des dispositifs
portés par les bénévoles de
vestiboutiques ce sont des lieux où nous
avons des vêtements
certes de seconde main mais pas que
parce que nous avons des dons aussi de
boutiques qui nous donnent des vêtements
et donc nous proposons à des tarifs
parce que il est important pour nous
mais je veux dire ça va être 50 centimes
1 Euro 2 euros et pour ces personnes
c'est aussi important de participer donc
nous avons des vestiboutiques sur une
majorité des territoires et
l'accompagnement se fait aussi au
travers des centres de santé comme comme
je le disais donc sans différenciation
de de
public et comme vous le savez madame la
sénatrice en Guyane nous avons la charge
de la seule plateforme d'aide
alimentaire de Guyane en fait il n'y a
pas de banque alimentaire en Guyane
c'est comme à Mayotte c'est la
Croix-Rouge qui joue ce rôle et comme je
l'ai insisté ce cette porte d'entrée est
vraiment importante pour nous pour
travailler avec les familles
voilà
sur la non-application de la me l'aide
médicale d'État à Mayotte vous avez
raison monsieur le sénateur
l'aide médicale n'est en effet pas
appliqué je vous savez la Croix Rouge et
neutre et ne va pas forcément
c'est un sujet politique comme vous
l'avez dit ce que je peux dire c'est
qu'en effet il y a un sujet de
convention des droits en général à
Mayotte parce que vous connaissez bien
et nous voyons en effet nous sur le
terrain que qu'il est important que ce
sujet soit traité mais la Croix Rouge
dans ce qu'elle
dans ce cas la porte est
financé on va dire pour tous les types
de public on ne différenciant pas
on joue
nous ne faisons pas différenciation donc
mais je comprends que ce sujet soit
important
[Musique]
sur
monsieur le sénateur Lamini sur les
moyens quels moyens faut-il pour
améliorer
vous aviez parlé
de
j'ai parlé de PSU outre-mer à étudier
évidemment mais avant de parler moyen
financiers je tenais à donc le rapport
pour nous que
en tout cas ce travail que vous faites
est très important pour mettre en
lumière l'importance de travailler sur
la parentalité en outre-mer et je pense
qu'en effet il faut quatre cartographier
les besoins
la particularité qu'on a c'est qu'on est
présent sur le territoire mais le sujet
n'est pas le même en Nouvelle-Calédonie
ou en Guyane ou en Martinique
ou en Guadeloupe la place du père
cette question de cohabitation conjugale
je ne sais pas si vous l'aviez en tête
mais c'est un phénomène très prégnant
aux anti en particulier en Martinique
les familles ne vivent pas ensemble donc
peut-être en termes de recommandation
cartographier les besoins en matière de
dispositif et par territoire
ce que nous on constate nous qui sommes
opérateurs de terrain c'est qu'on nous
avons une multitude de
partenaires
associations certes mais de financeurs
vous aviez parlé de la CAF de l'État des
collectivités des
collectivités donc CCAS de quand je dis
la CAF je parle pas de la CGSS qui
peut-être dans son action sociale peut
être amenée
qui est chef de file de l'aide de la
parentalité sur un territoire
c'est une question
peut-être peut-être alors j'ai une
réponse mais j'ai une réponse qui qui ce
que je veux dire c'est que peut-être
repérer sur les territoires le chef de
fil qui permettrait de voir de prendre
comment dire les différents financements
pour financer les politiques parce que
nous opérateurs nous allons en fait
répondre
à la dette qui va faire un appel à
projet politique de la ville la CAF sur
un autre sujet etc alors que vous voyez
comme la Croix-Rouge est très
généraliste nous souhaitons nous en
effet financé quoi des postes c'est
parce que on n'a pas un dispositif on a
des dispositifs des lieux d'accueil etc
mais on souhaite pouvoir travailler
lorsque nous accompagne on nous
accompagnons en matière de les familles
en matière de précarité alimentaire
c'est par ce biais là et on a et je vous
invite à venir nous voir sur le terrain
Mesdames et Messieurs les élus lorsque
vous êtes de passage sur vos territoires
de venir rencontrer de nos équipes pour
que vous voyez à quel point ce travail
transversal et est vraiment fait
c'est-à-dire que les portes de la porte
d'entrée n'est pas la parentalité
forcément la porte d'entrée va être
le besoin de s'habiller le besoin de
manger le besoin d'ouvrir des droits la
sécurité sociale
de besoin de trouver un emploi et si
nous réglons pas ces questions là nous
pouvons pas travailler les parents ne
sont pas disponibles et surtout pas
disponibles
nous voulons il faut aussi considérer
que les associations comme les nôtres
nous demandons tous les ans des
financements sur ce dispositif
imaginez dans quelle situation
d'insécurité d'instabilité juridique et
financière de nous trouvons les
dispositifs sont là ils vont pas
disparaître mais la demande de
subvention il faut la faire tous les ans
donc c'est un temps qui n'est pas passé
le temps de ses équipes n'est pas sur le
terrain même si on a la machine croix
rouge quand même je veux dire derrière
il faut considérer que ce temps de
réponse aux appels à projet est un temps
qui attend certains le nous proposons
qu'il y ait des
contrats plus lire annuels d'objectifs
et de moyens qui devraient pour nous
être pour les opérateurs comme les
nôtres un outil privilégié indispensable
c'est le cas sur certains territoires je
le citerai pas
c'est pas le cas partout nos
privilégions vraiment ce que je nous
portons aussi c'est que peut-être sur
ces questions qui un guichet unique
qui a un guichet unique
il faut rendre visible l'accompagnement
des personnes âgées
en introduction je parlais de tabou ou
de
non stigmatisation c'est qu'il faut
accompagner aussi la question par des
messages
au plus près au plus tôt nous sommes
pour on a un dispositif qui est l'option
pour un rouge mais d'autres que la
question
des stéréotypes de gens parce que ça
commence par là ça commence par là et
ben que cette question soit aussi
la question des stéréotypes pour vous de
l'égalité ou soit abordé
dans les collèges et on a on le fait je
vous l'ai dit on a
je vais continuer j'ai peut-être résumé
en termes de recommandation donc carte
graphie les besoins en matière de
dispositif définir un chef de fil en
matière des dates parentalité
déployer un plan spécifique d'aide à la
parentalité avec des moyens dédiés et
par territoire
on a veille l'outil le précédent outil
de plan la stratégie pour voter le pain
pauvreté sur les territoires a été très
nous on a vu les avantages il y a eu des
dispositifs financés sur certains
territoires grâce à au plan pauvreté
donc il faudrait peut-être envisager ce
type d'outils faire entrer la notion de
parentalité donc j'en ai parlé donc au
sein des collèges la notion de
parentalité peut-être passer par là
renforcer évidemment les moyens
les moyens financiers mais les moyens
financiers c'est nous permettre d'avoir
des ETP c'est ce qui ce qui est pas
simple parfois je le dis vraiment on a
l'état qui finance mais pas la CAF
parfois la collectivité donc c'est à
nous d'aller chercher et proposer des
dispositifs et
il faut qu'on soit ce soit co-construit
avec des partenaires comme les nôtres
améliorer l'accès au soutien
psychologique pour les parents
on peut pas travailler auprès des
parents si nous ne
ils rencontrent et on le voit de plus en
plus malheureusement et si ça neuf mois
pour avoir des rendez-vous en cmt sur
Sainte territoire on ne peut pas se
concentrer sur la dalle parentalité si
la personne n'est pas accompagnée
renforcer les structures
d'accompagnement d'accès aux droits mais
comme je vous l'ai dit l'essentiel c'est
de couvrir l'ensemble de des sujets et
un sujet majeur pour nous c'est
poursuivre l'effort en matière
d'agrandissement du parc immobilier
social
là ça concerne vraiment tous les
territoires en construisant des
ensembles à taille humaine et favorisant
la mixité sociale nous savons faire ça
aussi nous avons des tiers lieux
et nous souhaitons ensuite travailler
davantage sur la gratuité des services
pour les personnes éloignées de l'emploi
dans une démarche active d'insertion
pour permettre aux femmes d'accéder à
l'emploi
et enfin nous proposons de travailler
aussi un travail sur l'octoine mer car
les dons et bien de première nécessité
pour les enfants en bas âge
sur ces produits là donc on propose ce
travail là je souhaite voilà donc
vraiment peut-être rappeler là pour nous
l'aide à la parentalité est un sujet
mais le s'il y avait un message à faire
passer c'est qu'il faut travailler sur
l'ensemble des vulnérabilités des
parents avant de poser cette question
d'éducation et de dispositif
je vous remercie beaucoup et je vous
invite encore une fois à venir visiter
nos territoires et les dispositifs
portés par nos salariés que et bénévoles
que je remercie parce qu'ils font un
travail vraiment formidable
merci merci Madame la Directrice avec le
président de la délégation élément de la
délégation outre-mer nous vous
remercions pour toutes les réponses que
vous avez pu apporter aux rapports aux
collègues qui étaient présents ce matin
n'hésitez pas à éventuellement à nous
adresser des compléments de réponse par
mail ils seront intégrés à notre
réflexion afin d'inventer d'avancer
pardon sur ce sujet de la parentalité
dans les territoires outre-mer merci de
votre disponibilité et on va laisser
place à une autre réunion juste après
qui est à 10h15 je crois donc les les
réunions de travail s'enchaînent et nous
étions dans un temps contraint merci à
tous et à toutes bonne journée